[موسيقى]
تعامل مع المحقق في بدايه مجيئك الى
الاعتقال وقصه الاعتقال شيء والتعامل
بعدين مع السجانه العاديين شيء اخر السجان
العاديين هو مجرد عباره عن اله غير
انسانيه
وظيفته الوحيده في هذا المكان هو انه
يعذبك ويقتلك فاي استشداء او اي
تضرع يعني محاول الثليين مستحيله يعني
بتصيح يعني مثلا
بسموها حلاوه الروح يعني وقت بتكون تعاني
الام شديده جدا مبرحه من هذا تستنجد
تستنجد بالله تستنجد بمحمد تستنجد
بعضهم كان مثلا مشان الله مشان حافظ اسد
على اساس انهم يعني فهذه كان يزيد التعذيب
بمعنى ذاكره انا انه اسم حافظ الاسد اتوسخ
واطلع من تم هذا السجن انتقل
على المستوى الشخصي انا ضد داخل
المعتقل المعتقل بسجن تدمر يعني وصلت الى
تقريبا لا استطيع الحركه
النفيس التعزيز والكذا العمود الفقري كان
مضروب يعني كنت راح انشل يعني
فكنت عالي على الاخرين
بحمامي باكله بشرب
غسيل
لمده تقريبا
انتقلنا وتم علاجي وكذا سويت عمليه جراحيه
طبعا
كانت قاسيه على الوجدان وقاسيه على النفس
[موسيقى]